i was talking to jason
i can't not bring up the wedding you
guys just went to you guys both posted
about it you were emotional he said you
were emotional he wasn't just talk to me
about the moment it was special for you
right yeah it was absolutely beautiful
uh you know she's got impeccable taste
so the whole wedding looks fantastic
beautifully appointed flawless um but
he's never
been happier i've seen that dude be
happy but the pure joy that was like
radiating from his face
is was absolutely unforgettable is
honestly one of the like 10 sweetest uh
precious most precious moments i've ever
witnessed in my life and it wasn't even
mine
uh
i was happy for them man they were happy
you could tell like they worked hard to
get here they earned it and it was so
nice man they had a great day for it
everything in the script is something
either me or someone i know said i'm not
even supposed to be here today
i mean it's been so many years i i know
that you had mentioned before it wasn't
going to we weren't going to have a tree
quill if you would and now here we are
dude how stoked never say never it is
bliss man i mean i've been living with
this movie now since
we started shooting uh on my birthday
last year so august 2nd of uh 2021. um
so i've
i love what we've done
it feels like
a way to bring it all home it's a big
return it is chock-a-block full of
nostalgia you should bring tissues
out of joy and because it's emotional as
well
yeah
that's the thing it's a clerks movie and
people wind up crying and not because
they're like you ruined it like it's
part of the story and there's an
emotional pull to it so i i can't wait
for people to start seeing it i want to
talk a little bit about randall the
heart attack i know you pour yourself
into your into these movies how
important was it for you to add these
dynamics to these characters uh
everything i the authenticity of that
first clerks movie is kind of predicated
on the fact that i worked at that store
while we were making that movie so it
just drips with authenticity i don't
work at that store anymore now i own a
comic book store i'm no longer a clerk
and if a clerk acted like my clerk's act
at my store i'd be like you're [ __ ]
fired so
um at that point i can't lend that to
the movie i can't make a clerks movie
about the authentic experience of what
it's like to be on the front lines of
retail so you have to substitute
something else i can lend it the
authenticity of the heart attack that i
had that legit happened to me so i gave
it to randall and i can lend them the
authenticity of the movie i made
dare i say it because it's been said
this is the final installment
i mean what are your thoughts i think as
long as i'm breathing the possibility
there'll be a clerk something oh god
it's my
you know lucas had star wars this is all
i got so i'm gonna ride this right into
the ground i know he sold his stuff off
not me man i'll be doing clerks until i
go toes up off a set that would be the
ideal way to die
[Music]